tearing up the streets in 1995 and
destroyed the competition Dominic
Toretto is that really you yep Ichi has
been with Vin Diesel since the beginning
of his career including one of his
earliest jobs before he was a
blockbuster star they're called shark
buddies
[Music]
in 1995 et toward the American
International Toy Fair which is where
Vin Diesel was one of the many actors
giving their best sales pitch these are
our streets shark vehicles these are the
shark bikes this is a four byte for
shark cruiser and this is the ultimate
and get away gear doctor piranha let's
helo jet over here we have the
incredible hand sharks they're alive the
kids bring them to life kid controlled
punch the action jump look at that and
slow down guys
we have rip stir we have slob stir and
we have calamari there's a 90-minute TV
animated special coming out in March
then we have a 13 episode action-packed
series starting in September we're back
in these street sharks every step of the
way here are the wave one hand sharks we
also have something new for this fall
they're called shark buddies here they
are soft on the outside but the same
biting and punching power look at that
brotherly love
[Music]
haha that's right folks we back him
every step of the way
tearing up the streets in 1995 and
destroyed the competition and just three
short years later he found his breakout
role in Steven Spielberg's Saving
Private Ryan VIN told Ichi how his early
jobs helped put him on a path to stardom
I actually made my first film selling
tools over the phone so I would call
people up and then bagel them into
buying stuff you know selling them a
gross of lightbulbs that they didn't
need well this is how I would do it
throw it out and call up I'd say hey Joe
this is Paulie Joe hey Joe yeah this is
Paul down at the freight company I saw I
promised I'd get back to you if anything
new or exciting did come up well what's
come on we just got in these brand new
industrial technologically advanced work
gloves oh my god how much are they and
that's it that's a buying signal that's
that's if I'm really lucky normally they
take oh my god I already have gloves oh
you don't have gloves like these really
these gloves when you've got them on you
can literally pick up a dime off the
table Wow and you don't have to buy a
pound up
I've worked for a long time that's the
truth I worked for a really long time to
try to to make my dreams come true and
it's a it's a very strange feeling when
you realize that your dream has come
true it's it's surreal because it was
always just a dream who says heroes
don't have a soft side
[Music]